نحن في وسط بيروت حيث
توجد اشتباكات مرة أخرى بين
المتظاهرين وقوات الأمن ، هذا
هو اليوم الذي تلا تشكيل الحكومة
أخيرًا بعد ما يقرب من ثلاثة أشهر
من الفراغ السياسي ، لكن لا
يبدو أن هذا قد وضع حدًا لهذه الاشتباكات
المتزايدة.  اشتباكات عنيفة ، هذا
صحيح بولين حول تلك الألعاب النارية
التي يتم إلقاؤها على الشرطة الذين تم
إطلاق النار عليهم باستخدام قصب المياه والغاز المسيل للدموع
والكثير من الغاز المسيل للدموع ، نحن
على مقربة من سان هاتون في مايو أو
ساحة البرلمان والتي بالطبع لديها
لم يكن في الجلسة لفترة طويلة جدًا
نظرًا للفوضى التي كانت
تدور هنا ، فقد خلص العديد من الناس إلى
أن الاحتجاجات السلمية نحن الآن ما يقرب
من مائة يوم منذ بدايتها في
17 أكتوبر لم تسفر
عن النتائج التي أرادوها.  ومع ذلك ،
فقد تم تشكيل حكومة جديدة حكومة إلى
حد كبير من التكنوقراط ولكن
التكنوقراط مع الانتماءات إلى
الأحزاب السياسية هي حكومة أصغر
فقط 20 وزيرا  مقابل 30 ،
تضم 6 سيدات ، واحدة لأول
مرة وزيرة للدفاع ، ومع ذلك من
الواضح أن هناك بعض الذين قرروا أن
التنازلات التي قدمتها
النخبة الحاكمة ليست كافية ،
وبالتالي فإن هذه الاشتباكات مرة أخرى في
وسط بيروت مستمرة مع  لا نهاية
تلوح في الأفق ، أنا بن ويديمان أغطي قناة سي إن إن
من بيروت